quelle journée quelle journée quelle
journée toutes ces idées folles qui
change le monde je sais pas vous mais
moi j'étais inspiré
je propose d'ailleurs qu'on applaudisse
encore une fois tous les orateurs qui
sont passés parce que franchement il le
mérite et voilà
ce que maintenant ce qui arrive c'est
cadeau
vous savez comme vous le savez grecque
vous l'a dit j'ai passé l'après-midi à
écouter et à regarder toutes les toutes
les présentations qui ont été faites et
j'ai regardé très attentivement
alors j'ai essayé de comprendre certains
concepts qui étaient parfois très
compliqué et d'autres qui étaient
beaucoup plus ludique d'autres encore
qui était très anglais ou bien
d'autres qui étaient un peu plus ou un
peu moins
conceptuel on va dire
alors je vous propose donc de faire une
petite rétrospective sorte de résumé de
la journée en dessin puisque comme on
vous l'a dit c'est un peu ma spécialité
alors pour commencer il faut quand même
le rappeler on a eu la chance et
l'immense privilège de pouvoir
rencontrer bruce willis qui a peu fait
son nom de chott voilà
je vois que vous avez tous noté
l'harmonie entre la combi et l'homme
non après on a été quand même beaucoup
plus sérieux puisque on n'est pas en est
on a fait un bond dans le passé avec
dimitri lolë labourie pardon
l'égyptologue sm
alors je vous cache pas
alors
je ne vous cache pas que moi j'ai quand
même eu quelques petites désillusion par
rapport à la création des pyramides
suivante si je ne préférais pas le mythe
à la réalité mais bon voilà qu'il est là
alors
comme vous savez c'est un peu du live
donc je ne perde pas dans ma feuille
parce que les noms tout le monde c'est
pas facile à retenir alors après on a
rencontré dorothée goffin et sa
nourriture du futur
donc la question que je me pose c'est
est-ce qu'un jour on verra sortir des
frites light de ce machin là on verra
après s'il va l'audio nous a emmenés aux
confins de l'univers enfin c'est très
loin j'ai pas très bien compris où
c'était mais bon voilà c'était un
crosetta et filet
bon je sais pas vous mais moi j'ai quand
il a montré son poste de travail et
qu'il a dit que c'était l'endroit le
plus beau de la terre moi ça m'a juste
foutu les boules heures
alors après la personne qui est venue
après lui la première chose qu'on va
retenir c'est kosar kainry est venu
pieds nus
je crois qu'avec dorothée vont avoir
plein de choses à se dire
alors dernière est quant à lui à parler
des réseaux énergétiques et des
alternatives qui existent
c'est
c'est moi ou il a joué dans la grande
vadrouille
donc après on a quand même écouter un
collègue illustrateur martin sève
voilà
ses amis doivent plus jamais vouloir
jouer avec ce gars là
alors jamie anderson sais pas vous mais
moi m'a quand même foutu la larme à
l'oeil
mm j'ai envie de dire il m'a presque
donné envie de me remettre au sport
presque
alors
de retour du canada après notamment
d'appréhender les fera des tours au
canada avec richard martel sur le saint
laurent et sa balade en kayak entre les
déchets voilà
et si ce type vous propose d'aller voir
une bière avec lui méfiez-vous on ne
sait pas où ça peut vous emmener
alors après nous avons eu le professeur
philippe gabant qui nous a parlé de la
génétique
à en croire son talk je crois que il se
réjouit de la prochaine évolution est de
voir partir dans l'espace
alors après nous avons mis là nous avons
pris la mer avec claire nouvian
spécialisé dans la défense des fonds
marins et qui milite contre
la pêche en eau profonde
c'est moi ou elle a un problème avec la
france
alors après c'était expérience musicale
avec gaëtan ce trail
en tout cas c'était pas du pipeau
oui toutes les vannes sont pas du même
niveau je reconnais
alors après kung delvaux nous a partagé
son expérience de management
alors si son thème c'était de défier la
gravité
on peut dire qu'il nous aura mis sur
orbite avec son énergie
grégoire van cutsem qui nous a démontré
l'efficacité d'un marketing social en
remettre l'humain au centre
ce que c'est la solution nous sortir de
la crise je ne sais pas
enfin la personne qui m'a précédé
c'était christine zimmerman qui nous a
parlé de vertical farming une forme de
culture plutôt
renversante
voilà
moi quand je vois ça je suis contente à
vivre au village
voilà quant à moi j'ai tenté de vous
faire croire qu'il était possible de
faire du dessin à autre chose qu'à hobby
mais ça pouvait être aussi être un
brise-glace un outil une arme un cadeau
ou encore un véritable job
parce qu'après tout
comme le disait oscar wilde il faut
toujours viser la lune parce que même en
cas d'échec on atterrit quand même dans
les étoiles alors j'ignore si j'ai un
talent à l'une avec ces résumés ou cette
conclusion de la journée pour ça je vous
laisse seul juge
mais sachez que pour ma part je
quitterai la pièce relate les yeux
pleins d'étoilés